segundos después del aterrizaje de este
helicóptero hay una carrera desesperada
para llevar a los heridos a bordo tras
el terremoto de 6,1 grados
los afganos comparten vídeos y
fotografías en las redes mostrando
edificios reducidos a escombros y
cuerpos cubiertos con mantas
era medianoche cuando se produjo el
terremoto los niños y yo gritamos una de
nuestras habitaciones quedó destruida
cuando salimos había muertos y heridos
nos enviaron al hospital
la mamá de usted el terremoto se produjo
en la provincia oriental de paktika y se
sintió también en pakistán e india en
una reunión de emergencia los talibanes
ordenaron la entrega de alimentos ropa y
medicinas por aire y tierra también
prometieron mil millones de afganis en
ayuda monetaria es decir unos 10,6
millones de euros
bajo las órdenes del primer ministro se
ha decidido entregar 100.000 afganis a
las familias de las víctimas y 50.000 a
las familias de los heridos como ayuda
urgente
para la ayuda contra la catástrofe
podría suponer un gran reto para los
talibanes aislados en gran medida de la
ayuda extranjera las autoridades han
hecho un llamado a la comunidad
internacional a las organizaciones
benéficas y a las organizaciones
humanitarias para que hagan donaciones